[music playing]
NARRATOR: Off Alaska's southern
coast sits one of the most
dangerous spots on any map.
Kodiak Island.
3,600 square miles of
windswept unforgiving land.
Home to some of the most
unique wildlife in the world,
including the
fiercest predators,
the Kodiak Brown Bear.
While most wouldn't
dare to tread here,
Mike Horstman wouldn't dream
of living anywhere else.
First thing I ever killed when
I was a kid in upstate New York
was a bear.
I've always been
fascinated by them.
I always liked to hunt them.
I moved to Kodiak in
1979 to hunt brown bears.
I have sacrificed everything
just to hunt bears.
NARRATOR: Over nearly 40 years,
Mike's carved out a homestead
overlooking the Gulf
of Alaska and hidden
away from the world of men.
MIKE HORSTMAN (VOICEOVER): I
live out here, because there's
nobody else out here.
Bears are the only thing here.
And I wouldn't have
it any other way.
NARRATOR: Kodiak
bears are the largest
brown bear in the world.
And here on the island,
the population is thriving.
With an average of one
bear per square mile,
Mike makes his living
as a guide to outlanders
looking to hunt the big game
during the 11 week bear season.
I've guided bears on Kodiak
Island for over 30 years.
A lot of guys, this is
the hunt of a lifetime,
primarily because the
largest bears in the world
come from Kodiak.
NARRATOR: The rest
of the year, Mike
survives on a small inlet
known as Eagle Harbor,
50 miles away from
any other human
and 30 miles from the mainland.
But on Kodiak, Mike
is never alone,
even in the deepest winter.
These bears, it's not
unusual that some of them
don't go hibernate.
There's always one or two
that are wandering around.
They didn't get enough
to eat in the fall.
And they'll be poking
around, causing trouble.
NARRATOR: Without a
reliable hibernation cycle,
the island's bears are
a year round threat that
require a constant defense.
I've got that trail camera up
here alongside this bear trail.
We're going to go check that
and see what's going on.
I'd like to not have a
picture of anything on it.
If all we had is a picture
of a fox or a deer,
that would be perfect.
NARRATOR: To help
keep safe, Mike
makes daily rounds
of his property
looking for signs of predators
moving in on his turf.
What do you smell?
Something, huh?
[music playing]
You stay close to me.
You stay close.
[bleep]
There has been a
bear through here.
I'm concerned that he
could still be around,
traveling down this
trail, that he's going
in the direction of the cabin.
NARRATOR: Mike's
inland hunting cabin,
5 miles deep in
the Bear Country,
is a frequent target
for break-ins.
You stay close to me.
Stay close.
Right here.
What do you smell?
Pay attention, now.
[music playing]
It looks like something's been
in here and tore the door open,
tipped the freezer
over, clawed around.
Probably disappointed
nothing to eat.
The bear, apparently,
just went in there
and had its way with the
freezer for a few minutes.
But there's no fish or bait
or anything laying around.
So we were fortunate there.
Screen's intact.
All the windows are
intact back here.
I don't see any other
sign of the bear
going around the house.
NARRATOR: The unusual
behavior makes
the bears a constant threat.
And to survive here, Mike
has to be prepared to stand
his ground, at all times.
Hopefully, he went
on his way to the hills
and sleeping it
off, disappointed
enough with no food
that next year he
doesn't come through this way.
[music playing]